pour la flyer journalistes pour rt
internationale en direct d'ôter la vie
bonsoir aulas merci d'être avec nous
quelle est l'atmosphère surpasse à tel
aviv c'est le retour au calme dans les
rues
yasin goûter à l'animalité et depuis il
d'ailleurs deux heures du matin sur
place vendredi matin
c'est à ce moment là que le cessez le
feu est entré en effet et la vie et bien
honnêtement revenue à la normale nous
sommes au centre du pays au sud d'israël
cela a pris un peu plus de temps mais
maintenant la vie est de retour à
normale là bas également et les
israéliens qui vivait au fait de la
frontière sont retournés chez eux
les écoles sont ouvertes les commerces
sont ouverts la vie y est de retour pour
les gazaouis c'est également plus ou
moins la même chose il ya eu davantage
de destruction de bâtiments et de
logement indices plus beaucoup de
gazaouis elles n'ont pas encore de
logements
c'est beaucoup d'entre eux donc à la
recherche de logements temporaires dans
des écoles étant des bâtiments de l'onu
ainsi que des secours humanitaires ou
des bâtiments perdu les écoles ne
rouvriront pas à gaza
avant la résolution de la situation le
retour à une normalité elle chante tu me
picard les classes certes encore de
refuge pour beaucoup de personnes
s'intéressent maintenant à la situation
humanitaire à gaza tout comme j'avais
évoqué beaucoup de personnes qui nous
perdu
leur maison les nations ou midland plus
dead l'hôpital al-shifa principal de gaz
à riom que de matériel médical et a
besoin d'être mannequin majorité des
biens humanitaires qui entrent à gaza
depuis israël par le carrefour de carême
h à l'homme qui a été ouvert après des
fermetures sporadiques à cause des tirs
de roquettes à proximité transmise au
bénin carrefour et confère elle retient
rentrer à nouveau dans le chaos
donc la situation est à nouveau normale
oh la la trêve est tout de même fragile
n'est ce pas entre les deux camps avec
un incident d'ailleurs dans la journée
je n'ai fait il y a eu quelques
incidents depuis l'entrée en vigueur du
cessez le feu ce vendredi après midi
après les prières du midi il ya eu des
erreurs pendant deux heures dans la
mosquée de al aqsa en kz2 certains
jeunes pas la majorité où certains
jeunes sont entrés en confrontation avec
les officiers de sécurité israéliens sur
place ils envoyaient des pierres des
cocktails molotov
la police la police et l'armée a riposté
avec des gaz lacrymogènes et des
grenades assourdissantes
j'ai visité à de nombreuses reprises la
frontière entre gaza et israël depuis
vendredi le suisse et le flou tient mais
la grande question c'est pendant combien
de temps qui la mine depuis le hamas
prétend avoir remporté ce conflit on
reconstruit la fierté palestinienne
on est un paysage howling israël juin
côté israélien prétend également avoir
obtenu la victoire car il les aurait
détruit dans une part suffisante à
éviter les équipements militaires
je parle ici de spéculation de
commentaires officieux il faudrait il
avoir une nouvelle confrontation une
nouvelle guerre est bon ici 85 ans il ya
sept ans il ya déjà eu une guerre entre
hamas et israël
il ya eu par des gens sont d'accord pour
dire que il n'est qu'une question de
temps avant d'en avoir encore une autre
merci paul à slayer jour des expertes et
internationales en direct de tel aviv a